>>> AND WE'RE BACK WITBREAKING
NEWS.
A JURY IN TEXAS HAS REACHED A
DECISIONN THE DEFAMATION CASE
INVOLVING FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY
THEORIST ALEX JONES.
THE JURY DECIDED HOW MUCH
FAMILIES OF SANDY HOOK MASSACRE
WHO SUED JONES SHOULD BE
AWARDED.
CNN'S DREW GRIFFIN HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THE CASE ARE FROM THE
BEGINNING.
WHAT DID THE JURY DECIDE?
>> Reporter: IN WHAT SHOULD BE A
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR THE PARENTS
OF THIS MURDERED CHILD, THE JURY
DECIDED THAT ALEX JONES SHOULD
PAY COMPENSATORY DAMAGES OF JUST
$4.1 MILLION.
NOW, THAT DOES SOUND LIKE A LOT
OF MONEY, BUT THE PARENTS WERE
ASKING FOR $150 MILLION IN THIS
STAGE OF THE TRIAL.
THERE IS A SECOND STAGE, WHICH
BEGINS TOMORROW MORNING, WHICH
THEY WILL BE ASKED ABOUT
PUNITIVE DAMAGES.
THERE IS NO SPECIFIC TABULATION
ON WHAT THOSE PUNITIVE DAMAGES
WOULD BE.
BUT THAT WOULD BE TO ACTUALLY
PUNISH ALEX JONES FOR THE WRONG
HE COMMITTED.
THIS PART OF THE TRIAL WAS JUST
TO BASICALLY GIVE THE PARENTS
THE MONEY THEY THOUGHT THEY
DESERVED BECAUSE OF THE ACTUAL
DAMAGES THEY SUFFERED FROM
DEFAMATION, FROM MENTAL ANGUISH
AND STRESS THAT ALEX JONES
CAUSED WHEN HE LIED AND STRESSED
THAT THE SHOOTING, THE MASSACRE
AT SANDY HOOK, WAS, IN FACT, A
HOAX.
SO THIS IS A BIT OF A MIXED BAG.
THEY DID GET COMPENSATORY
DAMAGES, BUT, OBVIOUSLY,
$4 MILLION COMPARED TO
$150 MILLION IS FAR LESS THA